everybody and welcome to Planet Zoo this
is my first real video of the game I
suppose given that it's not the beta
anymore and if you're wondering how I
put this video out so quickly basically
me and a bunch of other people got early
access press release copies of the game
just to prepare the stuff for the
release dates on YouTube which is one of
the perks of being a youtuber I guess
although at the same time I have to say
I got this a week ago and in all this
time I've only managed to make this one
video so I haven't really made the most
out of it
but in my defense I spent most of that
time just messing him out in the game
trying to get used to the pieces and
trying to practice a little bit because
well I like to keep my channel based on
the assumption that I'm somewhat
knowledgeable and experienced about the
things that I'm doing which means that a
lot of time goes into these videos just
researching and practicing what I want
to do but especially when her new came
new game comes out it's like like this I
really want to put a lot of effort into
making sure I know what to do and how to
do things in the game before I move on
to making youtube videos and the same
kind of also goes for the strange
unusual formats of this video as you can
see I'm not really starting a series yet
at least this video is not called part 1
unfortunately maybe I should have done
that because the search engine
optimization that's how you rake in the
fuse I suppose but no I don't want to do
that kind of thing just yet because for
now I just want to keep practicing and
use these videos as a way to explore the
game see what you can do with it see
what the scenery pieces and the animals
are like and once I feel confident
enough to build a full park then I'll
make a complete Zoo series so that's my
plan for now so I'm continuing the
standalone builds of the zoo beta with
this build which I should probably
actually introduce we're three minutes
into the video and I haven't even talked
about it
so in this video I'll be building a
Japanese macaques habitat and we're just
gonna call them snow monkeys I guess
from now on because that's what people
usually call them and I have to say it
is a really cute name and so fitting
with the jab
theme I decided to build this whole or
to start this whole build off with a
building inspired by the Japanese
Imperial Palace in Chioda in Tokyo
although not really the palace itself
which is more of a modernist
reconstruction at this point but rather
the moats and the walls that are around
the palace which feature these really
cool towers at the corners which are
kind of like many castles those things
are really cool and they're probably
more famous at least their pictures are
than the actual Palace itself which is
rarely open to visitors it's really only
a couple of days a year I believe for
instance when it's the Emperor's
birthday but yeah you mostly just see
the the moats
if you're an average person like me but
yeah it's really beautiful and that's
what I was inspired by to make this
little building and I'm trying to at
least keep the promise that I made in
the Chinese Formosan bear habitats that
I will try to you know keep the animal
habitats very natural and keep the
cultural elements to different parts of
the zoo but this building in particular
will be sort of a decoration going over
the holding area for the mechanics so
there won't be actually sheltering or
anything like this in here but this does
hide what will in the future be a much
more simple sort of backstage thing in
which the mechanics can shelter and can
we care for and whatever backstage
elements you would need which I'm not
going to detail but you know it's staff
area a kitchen things like this so well
it's not really necessary to theme it
this much it is definitely a bit of an
over-the-top theming I think it's at
least somewhat vindicated by the fact
that it is over an actual functioning
structure which you do need to care for
the animals and the rest of this
habitats is mostly inspired by Japanese
gardens although here again I do want to
be quite strict and restrict the actual
Japanese garden elements to the
the elements to the parts where the
humans will be so when it comes to stone
lanterns and decorations like that I
won't be putting those inside the
habitats but definitely around the
surrounding area and the same goes for
some of the very typical Japanese
foliage that you can see in Japanese
garnets as well it won't be a full
Japanese garden build although if you're
interested in that kind of thing
check out my chapter knees Garland's
bleonard goes through series which I
made a while ago but rather just some
basic elements in this area to make it
all feel a bit more immersive and a bit
more Japanese well at the same time
keeping the habitats for the monkeys
themselves very natural and this is also
why I decided to have this small pond in
the middle of the habitats partly it is
to separate the guests and the monkeys
without creating a visual barrier
between the two and keeping them quite
close while not allowing the two to ever
really meet but at the same time it's a
very common element in Japanese gardens
especially lake gardens so it's
something that I wanted to get in here
just for the Japanese Japanese mists of
the overall aesthetic and you know it's
an excuse to build a stone bridge with a
bunch of detailing which will hopefully
look quite nice when all of the foliage
is in as well now speaking of the
monkeys and a bit about the habitat
itself and what went into my idea for
the habitat design I do know that
Japanese monkeys are decent swimmers so
these guys won't be able to actually you
know swim across the water and reach the
guests I'll try and have some anti
climbing stuff everywhere
obviously the habitat borders will have
anti climbing things on top of them but
hopefully putting some metal grids and
things like this over the pillars and
the walls of the paths will prevent the
monkeys for climbing onto them I'm not
sure actually I haven't tested this yet
I just hope that the game will not allow
the monkeys to climb climb that sort of
thing because in real life I'm pretty
sure it should be possible to stop them
from climb
into the guest areas with that and I'm
saying that with a decent amount of
certainty I did base this habitat on
quite a bit of research on real life
Japanese macaque habitats because
personally I haven't seen a lot the only
one that I think I've seen in person is
the one in tobu zoo which was actually
part of why I really wanted to start off
with the Japanese macaques as my first
ever planet to you know full game build
because I remember seeing that habitat
and they have this hot spring in their
exhibits which is really cool
perched on top of these rocks it's not a
very nice exhibit actually I have to say
but I really loved the idea of the hot
spring and the monkeys were actually
chilling in there as well so that was
nice quite stereotypical behavior I
guess as far as the sort of touristy
idea of what Japanese macaques do is
concerned but yeah I thought that was
really cool so I wanted to do something
like that at some point and then lo and
behold planets who came out and my my
dream of building a snow monkey onsen is
now pretty much a reality now aside from
tobu zoo I also looked up a lot of
pictures about the Detroit Zoo and
Lincoln Park Zoo habitats as well as
well as on zoo lacks the Tokyo zoo and
the grain and the Great Plains Zoo which
by the way for any budding zoo creators
out there playing this game sue likes is
a really cool website that somebody
linked to me on Twitter a long time ago
and I don't remember who this was so if
you're watching this video I'm very
sorry that I can't give you a shout out
here but yeah somebody told me about
this a while ago sue likes is a website
with lots of reference images and crazy
amount of detail regarding the all kinds
of exhibits really of all kinds of
animals all over the world and you can
really find a lot of information on this
be it's the the size of habitats the
design philosophy that goes into them
how the animals and guests are separated
and how animal welfare is kept in check
in the design it's just a really cool
website to look into if you're ever
looking for inspiration or information
on certain animals when you're building
a habitat Zoo likes is definitely a
great place to check out and even just
randomly exploring the website it's
seeing what's out there is really
interesting as well at least I guess if
you're kind of like me and your idea of
procrastinating is going on Wikipedia or
Google Maps and just looking up anything
and everything so yeah that would be my
recommendation of the day check out zoo
likes I'll link it down in the
description it's really cool and it
really helped me out with coming up with
ideas for this habitat as well anyway
I'm starting to run behind on things
that I wanted to talk about doing the
video so more stuff that I want to
mention about the habitat itself
I wanted to feature a lot of rock work
and try to mix not just the foliage but
also the terraforming with it in in a
conscious way and this is something that
I got really inspired about from Shawn
Mac beards videos he's a youtuber who
makes really cool planets to YouTube
videos in German I do have to give that
FYI so if you speak German or at least
understand it mostly like me I would
really recommend his channel he's really
good at the game he's is an old veteran
player of planet coaster who made
amazing stuff and they never finished it
mm-hmm
but yeah it's it's really cool and
especially his Wharf habitat videos
featured some really cool rock work that
kind of blew my mind because he really
purposefully sent out the terraforming
to create these sort of height gaps to
later fill them in with rock work which
is something that I never really thought
about that way and just started
experimenting with a bit in the rock
work in this habitat so you can see a
lot of that sort of horizontal layers of
rock work covering in some of the holes
in the terraforming some of the height
gaps which is really cool it just allows
the rock work to blend
the terraforming a lot more and to not
just you know pop out as a bunch of
random rocks from the ground because as
we all know 90% of YouTube videos on
planets who are just people placing
rocks so if it's gonna be that big a
part of the game might as well try and
get good at it so it's been a fun
practice to get a bit better at rock
work and trying to make it a bit more
natural and realistic also I'm thinking
of this right now so I just want to
shout this out if you notice that my
voice sounds a bit iffy I'm under the
weather again once again I keep getting
a cold recently I don't know why it just
keeps happening but this is pretty bad
timing so I'm just trying to power
through and I'll edit out some of the
coughs and sniffles when I'm done
recording but yeah if my voice isn't
exactly of the standard then that's why
I'm gonna need to live a healthier life
I don't know changed my diet or
something actually that's not the
problem I need to go outside more but
then there's also planning to anyway
anything I need to get back on topic
that would also be great
so something that I should also
definitely come back to which I talked
about a bit in the Chinese habitats
video is that I really want to make the
the nature in the habitat quite
realistic obviously there are a lot of
cultural elements around the habitats
which I want to keep outside the habitat
so just outside the habitat itself but
to make nature realistic and to make it
look like Japanese foliage I did have to
break some in-game rules a lot of the
trees that you see around here Oren's
really in the Asian section of the game
but are really my ideas for what I could
replace the generic foliage of the game
with given the fact that there isn't a
lot of specific Japanese foliage in the
game we do have the emperor maple which
is cool and we have the cherry tree
which is really cool but not really the
kind of everyday Japanese trees like the
Japanese black pine or different spruces
so for the for the black pine for
instance I ended up using Scots Pines
which don't really look exactly the same
but at least they have a sword
similar structure and I just ended up
putting a bunch of North American
spruces in as well so perhaps the
monkeys are going to complain about this
which to be fair they have all the right
for but yeah honestly I just wanted to
put in these trees to make it look a bit
more realistic even if in game it's not
entirely correct it's for me at least
and my suspense of disbelief a bit more
believable to see these North American
trees replace Japanese trees as opposed
to not having any pine trees whatsoever
or just being restricted to Himalayan
Pines which look way less like some of
the typical trees that you can find in
Japan and besides there are some
unrealistic quirks about the trees in
the game as well
we have emperor maples that are red
given the fact that not all emperor
maples are always red a lot of maple
trees in Japan are also just green in
summer it's a bit strange to have those
around at the same time as cherry
blossom trees because the Sakura the
season is also just really short and
only in spring so this is kind of a time
issue but then again these trees are
really most well-known for their
respective seasons with fall really
being seen as Momiji season in Japan and
spring really being Sakura season and
back to the topic of the animals
actually I also do want to make sure
that while people can look at them from
different perspectives and I'm trying to
immerse the path as much as possible
into the habitat of the monkeys I do
want to make sure that they have some
areas where they can escape the guest
views not to mention that there's quite
a social aspects to these guys as well
as far as I've been able to read they're
really social animals with hierarchies
as well in males and females and a
question of animal welfare and stress it
really relies also on the low ranking
individuals and how they feel in regards
to the high ranking individuals and how
these intergroup dynamics are and you
definitely want to be able to kind of
allow the the low ranking individuals
especially to get away from the group
every now and then if that's necessary
so I'm trying to at least give them some
hidings
and make the habitat large enough for
any individuals to get away from the
group as well
and as far as I'm able to tell these
kinds of influences can really even play
a bigger role than visitor presence
alone which obviously though can also be
reason for stress so definitely want to
be able to allow your your monkeys to
hide from people as well now in the
meantime I'm working on a pavilion which
will work as the main guest shelter for
the habitat which i think is also fairly
in theme my main inspiration for this
was actually material gardens in Tokyo
between Ikebukuro and Takadanobaba
station there's this old Japanese garden
it's really small
but it was a walking distance from the
Rikuo University which is where I did my
exchange in Japan so I went there just
to chill out and relax and look at a a
Japanese government which honestly on
pictures looks really big and then if
you visit in real life it's just like
wow this is this is really small but I
guess that just goes to show you how
good Japanese gardens are at recreating
large-scale natural landscapes at a very
small scale because at the end of the
day that's really a large part of what
Japanese gardens are trying to do with
different elements of the garden
reflecting natural elements such as
gravel waterfalls reflecting rivers or
rockwork reflecting real-life mountains
things like this and the the varied
organic shrubbery reflecting forests in
real life and from a distance and
certain perspectives these kinds of
early you know it's it's almost a form
of forced perspective techniques really
bring out a natural looking landscape at
a very small scale
anyway I'm getting very off-topic again
what I wanted to say is the garden has a
has a area with a small pavilion over
the water which you can view the rest of
the gun in from and I thought this setup
in particular it was
and that's what inspired me to have this
whole area be this this this stone
bridge that goes through the lake and to
have a pavilion over the water next to
this kind of infiltrating into the
habitat of the snow monkeys but at the
same time I did put some anti climbing
stuff on the pillars of the of the
pavilion there which hopefully will work
I'm really not sure we're just gonna
have to see when I put these monkeys in
in this habitat just based on what the
game calculates because it does allow
you to see you know the range that the
monkeys can go to so hopefully that'll
be fine if not then honestly I'm just
gonna see if I can deal with it I'm not
even sure if they're gonna be able to
swim in the game realistically in real
life there they are so I want to be able
to you know keep that in mind for the
design of the habitat anyway but yeah in
the game it's going to be relevant
whether they can swim regarding if
they're going to escape or not and then
when it comes to some of the other
details on the path work itself I'm not
really as concerned about security so
yeah the fences are just simple rope
fences with wooden posts and stone
elements I was kind of hoping that there
would be a fence like this in the game
as a standard elements but it doesn't
really matter you can very easily make
it yourself by the way I hope you don't
hear my chair it's being very loud hold
up now it was at this point that I went
back to Sean mcbird's video and looked
at the creek that he built for his
wolves which honestly is really cool and
really makes very great use of the new
water pieces that we have in this game
I'm saying new because everything in
this game just kind of feels new
compared to planet coaster it really
feels like an updated version of planet
coaster so everything kind of feels new
like a new object in something that I
know rather than just a completely new
game that's kind of strange but yeah
just trying to explain my questionable
word choice
there anyway Shawn built this really
cool Creek out of the waterfall pieces
in the game which works especially
because there are certain pieces that
simulate water rippling effects on the
water surface so if you just use a bunch
of these pieces you can make a stream
that looks like flowing water and then
at certain point points in the stream
whenever the water hits a rock or
whenever it falls a little bit you can
add some particles of the waterfall
where you can you can see it splash a
bit and altogether I think it makes
quite a realistic looking creeks and
definitely a million times better than
all of the water in Plymouth coasters so
that's mainly why I'm really happy about
these kinds of things being able to
build realistic waterfalls and things
like that was a part of the game which
was sorely missing in planet coaster and
really happy that these water elements
in planets who are so much better and at
this point I also wanted to build some
climbing elements and I didn't really
feel like making these you know very
man-made making these out of the
climbing platforms that the game
provides again I'm kind of screwing off
my stats here because this is not going
to help out the climbing statistic of
the habitat but you know these monkeys
like climbing and personally I felt it
would look better if the climbing
elements in habitats are natural as
opposed to man-made even though it's of
course all man-made but you know at
least look natural so I decided to go
with some logs some stems of trees
throwing them in different directions
and connecting them with fines that the
monkeys can climb on now at this point I
also decided to finish off some of the
surrounding perimeter of the habitats so
I'm trying to make it some sort of
combination between rock work and anti
climbing devices that I'm still not sure
what actually work but they look legit
enough to try and make this area look
natural at the same time preventing the
monkeys from actually reaching the
guests which would be catastrophic and
probably and the game would give me a
notification
a very dangerous animal has escaped at
that point even though it's just a
Japanese macaque but you know that's how
planet 2 rolls a tiny little zebra
escapes and it's like a life or death
situation for all the people involved to
this game at least actually maybe this
is a good time to give you some fun
macaque effects because I prepared them
might as well throw them out there so
apparently these are the most northern
living monkeys in the world they live
all the way up to the tip of Honshu
which is the main and largest island of
Japan now I'm saying the most northern
living monkeys of the world obviously
they're the second most northern living
we humans are the most known than living
monkeys but you know we're always in
first place as far as animal statistics
are concerned now monkeys always love
Japanese hot springs as well or sort of
I am actually gonna get into that in a
second because while I definitely agree
with them that Japanese on scents are
amazing the famous hot spring macaques
are in a place called G Goku Dani
monkey park and they're more of a recent
phenomenon they live in a park with a
man-made pool which is built from a
natural hot spring and the monkeys are
kind of kept here as a tourist
attraction they're not literally caged
in but they're fed here and as far as
animal behavior goes when you start
feeding multiple generations of animals
and they just come back and start
relying on the humans for food it's just
pretty much caged at least you know not
really physically but functionally it's
starting to depend on the humans in that
area and it's a bit strange I haven't
been there myself but from what I can
tell from scavenging a bit on the
Internet
it's not really even that much different
anymore from seeing macaques at a zoo
it's really popular nowadays and the
macaques are really only in this one
man-made poor with parts around it and
you can just constantly find tourists
taking pictures of them around in the
comics so it's very zoo like
which is a shame as well because
originally as far as I'm aware the
spring was actually built to save the
monkeys because back in the day they
were terrorizing farmers in the area
which we're getting sick of their antics
and then the pool was built and they
started attracting the monkeys to get
them out of other areas where they were
being problematic and the pool being in
a national park is quite convenient but
now that it is so popular it's it's very
much a different story and I really
don't want to say too much about it
given that I haven't been there and you
know this is supposed to be a
happy-go-lucky video but ethically I
feel it is a bit questionable apparently
the movie Baraka is the movie that made
the monkeys famous which if you're a
movie patrician it's definitely a cool
movie to watch it doesn't have a
narrative it doesn't really have
anything of a story it's just a bunch of
images that are really good-looking and
cool in a row personally I wouldn't even
be able to see it in one sitting just
short clips are cool but yeah next time
you see the monkeys in a movie like that
contemplating and relaxing and looking
very philosophical and natural and
beautiful realize that probably out of
frame there is a giant horde of tourists
taking pictures so I'm sorry for ruining
your dreams and for being it has a mist
here but that is the reality of the
Japanese monkeys in the the hot springs
in the snow and besides the play looks
very terrible if it's not snowing that's
something that it relies on as well that
said having hot springs in zoos has now
become more of a common thing well tobu
zoo from one has a hot spring Lincoln
Park as well that sounds like Lincoln
Park so yeah that is you can see
macaques in hot springs in other places
as well and it won't be that much less
natural than these mechanics that are in
Japan
now wait I forgot that I was trying to
list fun facts about mechanics one more
fact then they make snowballs which is
really cool and then we'll roll them off
of hills or things like this so they're
acting kind of human-like sometimes it's
almost like we're distant descendants or
something now in the meantime I've
almost finished up the Japanese garden
around the habitats just trying to fill
it in with many organically looking
small shrubs and elements and lots of
rock work to make it look like a
Japanese garden but at that point I
realized that I wasn't really happy with
this stone lantern that was in the game
not to say that it's a bad Lantern but
it's not really the kind of lantern that
I would place in a garden like this so I
decided to build my own stone lantern
which i think is very doable with some
of the classic pieces we have some
really nice and very small stone pieces
which you can make anything out of I'll
probably put this lantern on the
workshop and I'll put a link to it in
the description and whatever else from
this build I can put on the workshop as
well probably but yeah Japanese stone
lanterns are originally from China like
much of Japanese culture to be honest
somebody's got to say it and there are
many different types now specifically
this one is called a Yuki Maduro
which is a very typical garden Lantern I
was actually inspired to build this one
after q shabari q which is a garden in
Tokyo in shioma which has a really big
stone lantern next to the lake which is
very similar to this one and I always
thought that was really pretty and one
of my favorite spots in any Japanese
garden so I wanted to build something
like that so hence I'm building this
specific type of Lantern and a Yuki
Maduro specifically is a leg Lantern and
like all kinds of Japanese stone
lanterns apparently its parts are based
on the five elements of Buddhism I
couldn't find too many sources on this
but one of them is Wikipedia so I'm just
gonna trust them on this one
so the legs refer to earth water is
represented by the plates which are on
top of that and then on top of that is
the actual lights which represents fire
and then there is the cap the sort of
roof piece of the lantern which
represents the wind and finally but you
won't see much of this in the time-lapse
there is a small piece just on top of
the lantern pointing to the sky which
refers to the Japanese word of surah
which is hard to translate I suppose it
means air or heaven or sky or void
something very spiritual and up there
but yeah it's really cool to have these
sort of different meanings within the
lanterns and originally they also came
from Buddhist temples although now
they're being used in gardens and Shinto
temples as well but I've always been
really a big fan of Japanese lanterns I
would love to buy one although I
recently went on the internet to see how
expensive they are to get here in the
Benelux and they're pretty pricey if you
want to get the real deal so I think I'm
skipping on that one but yeah I think
they're really cool so I'll put this one
on my workshop and I'm not gonna appeal
I'm not going to throw any shade at the
lantern that is already in the game
because it's really nice but it is a
different type of lantern and not quite
the one that I was looking for anyway
with that built it is the end of this
time-lapse I just added some extra
things at the end like education in
donation boxes and part elements to
finish the habitats but at this point
it's time to open it to the monkeys and
to the public and see how they enjoy it
I hope you guys enjoyed this video in
any case and I'll see you in the next
one when hopefully I'll be a bit
healthier and I'll have some kind of
other standalone habitat built for a
different animal bye guys
[Music]
you
[Music]
you